ighil non oui l'état morph demi dieu du
vent et de la mer
je suis va y aller de soi en fait c'est
bah oui métamorphe de milieu du vent et
de la mer
idole des hommes ce quinté en bus
recommence et à des hommes à toi je suis
à tan tan tan et des femmes des hommes
et des femmes
les deux pouces voilà je veux pas
d'histoires non
bah oui et l'idole de tous des super
noms je viens au bien sûr questure oui
oui mon but bah oui a toujours le temps
pour ses fans
quand on prend un oiseau pour écrire ça
s'appelle twitté alors je sais c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on a la chance oui lol
je ne suis pas venu parce que je voulais
un autographe
qui rend plus
génération entre familles a vécu en
sécurité sur cette île paisible mais au
delà du récif un danger nos manas
la légende parle d'aero
si donnera l'océan à la recherche du
demi-dieu mauri
ensemble ils pourront nous sauver
noël aux lots bah oui mais d'abord demi
dieu du vent et de la mer
je suis violent des hommes en fait c'est
ma wii métamorphe demi dieu du vent et
de la mer et dole des hommes jeunes
interrompent lui désolé recommence idole
des hommes à toi t'es qu'une gamine pas
question ça c'est ma pirogue et tu vas
venir jusqu'à technique
alors ça j'ai pas vu venir
l'océan est mon ami
premièrement on va devoir traverser un
océan de malheurs lesquin camorra les
quatre cas quoi
1 ils sont trop mignons
bahia n'a je te coupe oui le run tour
non c'est pas vrai une fléchette dans la
fesse nous allons envoyer une démo sera
folle pas c'est encore bien pire que ce
que tu crois